so I'm a huge fan of reality television
and uh and I have uh I have little use
for it
yes all right well but no we agree on
one thing that reality TV has completely
gone bananos is redink to the hulas it
is it is it used to be very simple it
used to be just live in a house and
we'll film it and then we'll do the same
thing next year and it was yeah it was
like that for 10 years and then all of a
sudden it turned into you can live in
the house but we might kick you out if
you don't run the raw diet food co-op
correctly you know that's right and then
it was no house for you live on a beach
starve and make alliances with each
other right when that show happened
that's when it went to straight up
nutburgers crazy time all of a sudden it
was be a gay man designing things and
get angry at other gay men designing
things or mad lesbians in a kitchen yes
please install a television on my mode
of transportation mhm eat a bug win a
car mhm